meglio a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa vj oggi ho deciso
di fare una scommessa se proprio
vogliamo metterla visive ho deciso di
scommettere il mio account di instant
con chi lo scommetto lo scommetto contro
giulia penna e con email
lo scommettiamo facendo delle challenge
con i ragazzi sei mesi e se giulia penna
vinceranno questa sfida si prenderanno
il mio account instagram
ripensandoci procedo ai mezzi mio
profilo instagram
non ho idea di che cosa possono tirar
fuori quindi se mi state guardando sono
morto tattica kang sok allora questo è
un videomessaggio che arriverà
direttamente i mezzi giulia penda ci
siete
[Musica]
salve ragazzi se state guardando questo
video significa che sono già slogato
dalla mia eredità digitale comunemente
detta easter se volete raccogliere la
mia eredità digitale dovete recarvi in
questa posizione non posso dirvi altro
buona fortuna
[Musica]
e perché loro ci ha fatto dire qui
perché è così buio ho paura si paga ma
lo staff e qualcuna tutto in ordine al
solito quello che sta organizzando una
festa in maschera di prova ragazzo e j
dov'è sole madballs però pieno di roba
qua c'è anche la macchina di ritorno al
futuro
godzilla security e filo questo mi
ricorda tanto quello di mio padre
chi paga 26 andare di qua quelle luci
mio amore c'è
aspettatemi malore ragano cosa
organizzato consiglio non ci quello che
va fatto questa roba tipo 2 con gli
assomigli a salve ragazzi e ragazze vi
spiego ho visto il nuovo film di steven
spielberg eredi player one e sono giunto
ad una conclusione
noi siamo tutti quanti figli di un mondo
digitale ogni videogame che abbiamo
giocato ogni finché abbiamo visto ogni
supereroe nel quale ci siamo
immedesimati ci ha lasciato in qualche
cosa potrebbe lasciarci un potere questa
lezione non imbratta da james halliday
che in grado né dell'oasis mangiatevi
tipo di avere tutti i supereroi
dopo i preferiti le armi del nostro
gioco preferito è protagonista nel
nostro film preferito tutte messi
insieme in un unico e solo mondo
per dar vita ad un'avventura incredibile
ho scelto voi ragazzi perché potreste
diventare una squadra affiatata come
quella nel film life fare
partiamo da steps to sarà il punto di
riferimento della squadra sarà i pards i
vasi l'avatar da wade vuote ma ci
somiglia ma è caruccio perlomeno giulia
tu sarai la sua spalla la temibile
artemis carrozza a cavalli chiave cast
sarà il più robuste forzuto della
squadra di gigante e anima e suri voi
sarete due ninja della squadra i
popolari per andare a facili
sarete tipo dai tuoi shop guardato che a
voi ragazzi se riuscirete a completare
tutte le sfide otterrete il premio
supremo si sa che cos'è che lascia la
bassa del canale che è la mia eredità
lista quindi non solo avrete l'accesso
al mio account di instagram ma troverete
anche liste reggae più importante di
tutti
la verità ma vi ho già detto che
dobbiamo indovinare dobbiamo dove per
indovinare tre film in cinque minuti ci
sono delle locandine alle pareti le sto
vedendo e ci sono delle parole che non
ci posso dire per farvi indovinare
addetti qua c'è il primo smesso anche
degli ostacoli devi spostare allora è un
film una coppia una coppia una voce
anche i vostri giornali né chi possa
proprio familiare
no no un tipo santi gialli con il
pigiama a righe non è troppo
dovete fare sotto a questi si vede
scendere solo non dovete mai visto che
abbiamo allora allora ci sono degli
animali animali estinti respira
[Applauso]
c'è un tipo che picchia la gente tanto
abbiamo visto già perché facendo
inerenti questa pista di moda tutor
l'aveva consideriamo la challenge
completa e passiamo alla seconda che è
meglio
2 3 4 5 7 8
un ragazzo allora vi preparate staccati
avg ha detto due sacchetti sono cianni
possiamo vedere dai 54 57 di fila
[Musica]
abbiamo provato ma entriamo adesso
clemeno pezzo teramo buono e quindi
lorenzo parziale poi ed efficienti
imparziale è stato bravo 3
ma io ho un mondo il massimo dei bravi
giuro
passiamo la terza è stata facile qua è
messo in gioco dei due centri di casa
questa è l'ultima channel 100 rana
vincerà perché è in ora che fanno
quadrare quanti punti devo fare 1500 106
100 ragazzi trevi bene anche una targa
tutto da capo se volete gioco
io sono bravo dei nostri cambio va
benissimo
ora che sono dove non sei mai dato di 20
40 ecco le dittature non ci capisce
l'ultimo fatta sempre sull'ultima
secondo me ancora molto stata
generazione che siano cui lei si invase
1000 punti e c'è anni hanno bruciato di
animazione sociale sia per i gialli già
raggiunti spara a 130 punti
[Applauso]
anche la sedia cosa di tutto quello che
già è a casa base
complimenti ragazzi il mio esis vostro
potrete fare un takeover della mia
pagina instagram per una giornata intera
ma la cosa più importante avete capito
qual era il vero tesoro rava parsifal
anzi bravo partita era esattamente
questo il tesoro ora andate siete liberi
di andare al cinema di vedere il film di
prendere il controllo del mio instagram
come vogliamo
le foto imbarazzante da caricare nostre
si lamentino bambino per email
occhio che vi spezza le gambine in base
a quello che pubblicate dal regista
steven spielberg questo è un universo
virtuale per salvarlo affronteremo tre
prove impossibili
chi vincerà avrà il controllo completo
di oasis it il futuro re di player one
dal 28 marzo al cinema
[Musica]